violence vandalism
addiction a leafy suburb turned into a
junk strewn nightmare a birmingham
neighborhood which claims it's under
siege
you name it we've seen it we've had
people
cars attacked on the road just on this
stretch here there was seven vehicles in
one night
wing mirrors of cars being attacked the
hypodermic needles in the tyres
the problem here and in other cities is
family homes being turned into what's
called exempt accommodation
which house high densities of troubled
tenants providers charge the council
inflated rates
and are supposed to provide the tenants
additional support
but we've found the systems flawed
majority of them are drug addicts
uh some of them have got mental health
uh
some of them are alcoholics there was a
guy recently
who took an overdose and died in the
house upstairs as well
so there is quite a lot going on here
emma lives in an exempt property which
she currently has to herself
but recently shared
emma sent this video to her landlord
complaining her flatmates were taking
crack cocaine in the communal area
he's in a crack house and he said that
none of yous are smoking it
reach one she says the man in this video
died
three weeks later and the requisite
support was lacking
i kept complaining and said it's not
wrong i said what they're doing isn't
right
and then about three weeks later that's
when the guy upstairs got found dead
and i turned around and i said to the
staff here i said i told you
providers ox hill house say they did
offer support
and the resident died of a lung
condition but a sky news investigation
has found
a systemic problem with other providers
there are reports of domestic violence
victims
being placed with men who have a history
of violence
this man spencer hobson was not risk
assessed by his provider in northampton
before he stabbed his flatmate to death
there was a similar case in birmingham
last year
it was these people either they'd come
from the prison
they're uh you know have drug habits
all sorts of yeah you know the
unsociable sort of people that you don't
want here and so on and it's also become
very difficult because a lot of families
still got children here
um and often you know walking down the
streets you'll see condoms you'll see
needles you'll see all sorts of things
and over supply of exempt homes
means families are getting stuck in
temporary properties
the mother of two toddlers living here
for a year didn't want to appear on
camera
you can see the mold on the drawer and
all the clothes are smelling as well
windows are broken it's damp
and infested mouse is in the drawer oh
god yeah
let me see there his mouse is around
this cockroach is around because i've
still i'm storing everything in these
containers which are easy for me now
the transient often overpopulated houses
turn streets into dumping grounds
in birmingham exempt accommodation has
doubled in 18 months
and the council says they can't stop
landlords some
linked to organized crime from funneling
problems
into their communities so we know that
there's a lot of um
providers and organizations that are
directly going
to places like probation services or
prisons or other places like that
outside of the city and asking them you
know we've got properties do you want to
actually let you know let through us and
these are providers that we wouldn't
necessarily put people in ourselves as
the local local authority so you can
understand why some people on some
streets say it feels like we're living
in an open prison
absolutely and we've got absolute
empathy for them
birmingham and other councils want
greater powers to contain the problem
the ministry of housing told sky news
we're currently running extended pilots
in five areas
backed by 5.4 million pounds trialling
new approaches to crack down on the
small number of landlords
who provide inadequate support to
vulnerable people living in supported
housing
the housing regulator says it's
monitoring non-compliance in this sector
but many say the system is simply a mess
and needs urgently
changing jason farrell sky news